so today's topic is quite controversial
but it is the topic of why men and women
become disloyal yeah so we want to know
what causes a woman to go down the route
of disloyalty I I've seen this happen
where they go for like you mentioned
actually Kim kashian the Beyonce they go
for women who to them look good
aesthetically but their character is a
man could go and be intimate with
another woman and it can mean zero to do
you kind of think it's maybe accepted in
society yes I was l women are more
frowned upon if they're cheat but men
it's it's normal he's taking his wife
out he's buying her stuff and she's
being ungrateful for it and that's like
a disrespect to how he feels because he
would be literally saying I'm doing as
much as I can and it's not being valued
the reason why Allah tells woman to
cover up is so we don't fall in love the
wrong way not love lust the wrong way
because it protects you and it protects
me cuz when you're covered I'm speaking
to you not speaking to something else if
a man cheats on his wife that man is not
to be trusted by other men and you
shouldn't go into business with a man
that cheats on his wife don't want the
commitment of a second wife Financial
burdens they want to have their
short-term pleasure they don't want that
commitment that's that's what most guys
that's why they cheat a wife holds high
value for a month so that's the only
woman that can hurt emotionally the rest
of the women are just exactly you know
what theyve raed in their head this is
my go this is my girlfriend or wife
whatever done now I'm going to I value
her and she's mine but the rest are
nothing and today women they have no so
they throw at these days women are thr
at men if there is a sister whose
husband is you know he's gained that
respect from her most likely I believe
what what husband says that you have to
gain my love I feel like you're
disrespecting me as a man and she said
well you have to earn my respect imagine
the the the man the woman comes and says
I don't feel like you love me you're
affic well you have to earn my love oh
you guys don't like it okay so you guys
okay so one second one second why is it
that a man has to earn his respect but
if the woman is saying look emotionally
you're not giving me love yeah and then
he says well you have to earn my
love
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be AAR for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you will in
be reaping the reward click the link and
donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshah
welcome to another episode of The Bitter
truth show
um the show has um we started the show
me my wife and the team anas jabby and
the rest of the crew may Allah bless
them our aim is to preserve the family
units there's an outright attack with
divorces the whole lgbqt all that kind
of stuff so we're here to talk about
issues that are pertaining to matters
that cause divorces um uh one of the
other aims is to understand opposite
gender better for them to understand us
better and to have a civilized dialogue
with and AD without backbiting
slandering uh and hope this is some kind
of a um a an example for you guys uh how
obviously we know uh when it comes to
you know interacting with opposite
gender uh Islam is clear on this matter
um but it's to show you guys that Muslim
men practicing Muslim men and practicing
sisters our honorable sisters we can
come here and talk about issues uh that
are pertaining to our Dean that affect
our lives and our families uh and hope
this an example how inshah to conduct
yourselves so if you want to apply and
be a guest the bit Tru shop gmail.com
you can apply there in
and be a participant uh but Today's Show
we we did one um couple of weeks ago was
uh why why women cheat while they
disloyal um and we discussed that we
didn't have time to fit this in but so
today we have different guests different
uh speakers as you can see and the topic
at hand is why do men cheat why are men
disloyal what causes them to go disloyal
uh to become disloyal so we're going to
start off I'm assuming we start with the
men you guys want to get an
understanding maybe before we go to you
guys unless you want to say you want to
no yeah we'll start with the men in yeah
so from our psychology our perspective
uh what causes us men to uh be disloyal
and again um disloyalty we need to put
into some you know make some disclaimers
here at the end of the day it's Zena
adultery um Zena if you commit z um it's
not actually disloyalty in that sense
because you're you know you're not being
unfaithful in that sense because you're
not married already so you're basically
um committing an immoral act which is
100 lashes uh if you are married the
capital punishment is very clear I'm
sure you guys know I don't need to go
into detail um and it's from Islam and
it's the H um so when it comes to this
issue we do still have men but we just
want to understand the psychology
because we know it's a major sin it's
it's it's a major major sin which which
holds death penalty in that sense unless
that's obviously just um talking about
Hadith of the Prophet mammad if PE be
upon him where a woman came and even a
man came and said I I committed adultery
and the prophet peace before him moved
away from him like moved and just
ignored him and he said oh miss of Allah
I've committed adultery he moved from
him again and the third time he was
insistent and he said maybe you just
kissed her so he was trying to say
listen because what that shows you is
the Sharia is not blood first looking to
apply punishments it's just averting as
much as possible but when he confessed
for the third time he had no choice the
prophet peace be upon him but to apply
that punishment at his
discretion so much so that the narration
says that when he was obviously being
stoned yes um that at one moment he
actually escaped and run away and some
of the companion chased him to should
say to finish the job in that sense the
prophet was upset said why did you have
to chase him the point is that and there
was a woman who came and she was
actually pregnant and the prophet PE
upon him again said look just maybe you
know whatever she was like no she was
adamant um so much so the prophet P said
okay once you give birth you know maybe
thinking you know she might might come
and give birth and change your mind and
say look I've repented Etc which you can
you can secretly repent for this matter
um again this is what happened and when
she was she got the capital punishment
some of the blood went on the shoes of
one of the Companions and he actually um
acted in a way of like repulsed by it
and the prophet P said something so
profound and and it gives me shivers to
this day like even saying it right now
he said because he was repulsed by the
blood like oh this is an adulterous
woman he said by Allah her repentance
what she did now
willingly would be sufficient for Medina
to show The Honorable State cuz we would
look at this woman and people back chat
and in Islam Islam the prophet PE say
her her repentance that you reports by
her blood W it will be enough for the
like her repentance so we need to
understand Islam's views very specific
in this manner sorry for that lecture in
that sense because we need from Clarity
it is a major sin but putting that to a
side what causes a man to even think
about this your read you are you we've
got a new brother here may Allah bless
you yes can you just maybe introduce
yourself my name is ibraim I'm married
I'm 40 years old 41 M come on you look
33 alhamdulillah M you just be nice yes
I'm
4 I'm being very genuine you look like
34 so yeah I'm married with quite a lot
of children oh two different marriages
okay Mah like um simultaneously or
divorce I tried to go for the
simultaneous one didn't work it didn't
work alhamdulillah okay no problem it
happens happen Okay um and you're you're
kind of a regular you've come before but
again
yeah two
mics yeah I was on I think three
episodes before wasn't
I okay yeah so I was on a few episodes
before and this is my fourth one I'm a
university student doing International
marketing and consumer psychology and I
can't be to speak about myself so I let
everyone else speak now okay so let's
get straight into brother you're married
what causes a man to think about this
loyalty act upon it or pursue it or
whatever and this loyalty can come in
different ways by the way um the thing
is uh if we're talking about a real man
you know we're talking about a real man
who looks after his family and takes
care of his family I think is um the
attention if he doesn't get that
attention at home uh he will go do
something uh but the thing is if he
doesn't have that connection with his
wife and not talking to her what the
problem is and that will kind of lead
him towards doing something he shouldn't
do but I'm talking about a real man but
some men just cheat because they they
just want to cheat there like different
kind of thing that you need to look into
but I think a real a real man um that
you know I think first of all if if
there's a situation like that he should
try his best trying to sort the
situation out but if he's not getting
sorted and he's not getting attention at
home with his wife that will lead him
towards towards do something that he
shouldn't do okay so um brother is that
reason yeah I'd say Reas there's
multiple reasons right but I'd like to
open up by saying I think there was 25%
of women in a marriage cheat according
to Muslim skeptic 40% up to 40% of men
cheat in a marriage what's skeptic it's
like a he's a big YouTuber I think you
know Daniel H right according to him you
said that so he's done his own
statistics and stuff you can you can
look up yourself okay yeah yeah that I
need to find that's fine that's what I'm
I'm quoting The Source exactly yeah so
that shows that obviously men cheat more
than women right and we're sort of going
to discuss why they do that so one of
the reasons is because the family home
he doesn't feel like he can get what he
needs out of his wife so he goes looking
for it elsewhere I think a lot of that
is to do with sort of sexual desires so
he's not sort of getting what he wants
in that department so he's cheating he's
getting escorts whatever that may be um
I think that's a big contributing
factor bah um I think like everybody
agrees that we're living in a society
today that opens the platform for Zena
and adultery to take place from the very
young age from when children are
watching things from TV the whole
concept of boyfriend girlfriend the
Loyalty of family has been completely
broken broken down and we growing up in
that environment where parents are not
even discussing this idea of the value
of a marriage in depth with the children
people are getting married very
immaturely and they haven't truly
understand the value of what marriage is
what loyalty is the responsibility that
it carries so when men for example some
men are immature in the sense they don't
know what they want they walk outside
the TAA is low and they engaging with
women at work they engage with women
whether you're a taxi driver you work in
an office they see a lot of fitner
around them and the opportunity is very
easy and because their understanding of
commitment of marriage and what it means
and they don't think about the
repercussion of their actions until
later on and sometimes it's a bit too
late so there's lots of different
factors for different people we live in
a societies where people from many
different backgrounds so we don't always
understand the person that we're married
to everyone's got different values and
when you put all of this in context
together you're going to see men are
cheating for various reasons some of it
like I said is immaturity they don't
understand the value of their
partner
and that's some of the
points so it's actually similar to what
everyone else has just said right now
and this is also common with women as
well it's actually
relational relational neglect so the
husband would literally be you could say
he's like he's doing all of his work
he's taking his wife out he's buying her
stuff and she's being ungrateful for it
and that's like a disrespect to how he
feels cuz he would be literally saying
I'm doing as much as I can and it's not
being valued so similar to what brother
Sage was saying would be that because
he's not feeling valued with all the
work he's putting in his own house he's
going to try and get that from somebody
else same thing would happen with a
woman where if she's not feeling valued
for the work that she's doing and she's
not getting attention from her husband
despite doing as much as she can in the
house and with the kids she too would
also be doing a similar thing where she
should be looking elsewhere for the
attention and then you have more of an
immature angle where it's you have not
men but you could say little boys where
they have this very very high sex drive
and they they can't control themselves
when they literally leave the house and
these are usually people that
have the Taqua is not very good they
can't lower their gaze everything they
see with like women and stuff they seem
as like a piece of meat so they'll
literally if they have the ability to do
so they'll hide it from their wife and
they'll just do it behind their back but
the ones that you would feel that um is
more complex is are the men that are
actual men they're doing as much as they
can for their family as much as they can
for their wife doing XY Z and going out
of what you'd expect from man like
they're doing so much and when it's not
being respected and they feel UNG great
say the wife feels ungrateful for what
she has that's when I feel as though the
man would want to Outsource it somewhere
else so he can feel valued and
respected um but this I think instead of
saying why men cuz men have a um
permission to get married again so
should we say why men seek another woman
because then we can come it from an
angle not just by cheating because
sometimes Men We men desire other women
for variety of reasons that's another
reason as well cuz that's needs to be
added in because otherwise why classify
what cheating is so in this instance can
we say cheating is physically um doing
something with another woman while she
already in a marriage because if you're
seeking another a wife which is halal
you're not going to be engaging should
we say why are men seek why do men seek
another woman because because we have
element of marrying again because
because then sisters can understand okay
why why why is he why is he seeking
another another woman because we did
when we did why woman cheat we realized
that woman cheat in two ways there is
one is emotional and there's a second
which is physical which the man does as
well emotional cheating is different
because if she feels neglected we
discussed that if she feels like she's
not being hurt Etc she will get and
crave that attention somewhere else no I
think we should keep it to why men cheat
because we we know why men seek other
women because you're polygamous by
Nature that's
why by nature men can go with multiple
women we know that already okay good
then let's let's why men cheat okay but
if you want to relate it to that a lot
of men I've met I've tried to do help
people get married when I was staying in
Bradford for a few years and I spoke to
brothers who wanted and did speak to the
wife about having a second wife when the
wife refuses the man doesn't want to
break up a family he wants to protect
his family carrying looking after the
wife but he does have urges or needs or
he might want to just for whatever
reason have another the wife he will
then go and look to get another wife but
he doesn't want to destroy the family
that he's already got and he might be
that risk taker who's going to go and
okay so all right that's how we've
discussed a lot in this topic I don't
want to get into that which like I said
before it's valid where it's okay we
know men sometimes they desire another
woman they just desire another woman
there's nothing to do with you we've
discussed that so many times I don't
want to get into that okay but why do
men want to like let's see if if that
factor wasn't there why do they go down
the route of being this L cheating like
I believe like me I believe number one
it is not low in the gate where is
watching pornography definitely coming
from a background especially like if
he's a re come from a Jah that to get
out of his system is going to take good
of a while um if he is known to be
promiscuous before like I said before
that's going to be an element um if he
is not sexually attracted to his wife
anymore argument s we discuss this about
um when to have kids about when when the
woman has a child her body changes Etc
um that's plays a role um from my the
top of my head that's I can guarantee
you that most men most men cheat do you
kind of think it's maybe accepted in
society that yes I was literally going
to say women are more frowned upon if
they're cheat but men it's it's normal
because cultures so so so that's that's
also a reality um that that is true
which is that's the reason why they say
women don't cheat women do cheat women
don't get caught because men don't
expect them to cheat uh because of their
high so that's the reason why men get
caught because women know what they're
about so they're on a case so men get
caught easier because men are known it's
like it's like they have a stigma known
for it because women of the and Etc a
man would never I believe any man who's
married would never think my wife will
be disloyal it's just a given an
expectation of that will never happen
that's why they can usually get away
with it easier because you don't expect
it but a woman bro she's on your K she's
checking your phone she's doing some MI5
stuff yeah so that's why that stigma is
there I think that's why it becomes a
norm um I think and also I think maybe
because if a woman cheats the
consequences are greater because she can
by the way in Islam Zen is z adulter is
adultery the punishment is the same I'm
not saying they're different but if you
look at it a woman can ascribe a child
to that man he doesn't know which can be
which is greater and more maybe shunned
upon when it shouldn't be I don't know
but let me let's hear from you guys from
our from us I think that's it okay so um
relationships what are we looking for
fulfillment that's the main kind of
priority fulfillment in a Rel
relationship now when that fulfillment
isn't met there's a void a void that
we're trying to fill so now some people
they'll fill that void with addiction
some people will feel that void with um
going out committing sinner so it
depends on the individual and where
where they're at in that relationship so
it's not just about okay why do men
cheat or why do women cheat or we know
all the answers but it's a void in us
now some people they're not connected
they don't have that TAA they're not
connected to allaha tala and like the
brothers mentioned those of us you know
who are connected to our Deen who are
connected to Allah I believe is less
likely that individual is going to go
out and commit Zena less likely I'm
going to use the word less likely there
may be people out there that portray
that they do have that connection and
you know like Brother Ali mentioned
before the brother with the beard and
the Quran and the thorb and everything
so um yeah that's kind of my take on
that there's a void that
people try to
feel I think um it also has a lot to do
with the company you're surrounded by if
you have your if your Social Circle is
you know it has your your friends
basically around you are within that
company and you're influenced by it
because it happens there's a lot of
people that I know you know personally
knew as well that have been in Social
their friendships have influenced them
to do these kind of things they could be
the nicest person they could be the most
um you know the person who's connected
who has the fear of Allah who's
connected to their Deen but because of
their company and their Social Circle
they've gone and committed zenner or
adultery and it's just the impact that
their friends have had on them so I
think your company um matters in those
um in that aspect too people you hang
around with people you work with
Etc um for me when PE when men cheat or
why men cheat I would say firstly it's a
character
flaw um it's a lack of
discipline it's a lack of uh Dean Taqua
all of these things um it's a lack of
honesty because I feel like men do
anything but communicate efficiently and
the the first thing you go to do is
cheat like sometimes have that
communication have that conversation
with your spouse to say well you know
you're not fulfilling or this and this
is not going right um I need you to step
it up or blah blah blah but a lot of men
tend not to do that they'll have they'll
say it once or they'll speak to their
spouse once and then they start to
wander with their eyes and things like
that but to me it's a character flaw um
and it definitely shows lack of
discipline and for me if a man cheats on
his wife that man is not to be trusted
by other men and you shouldn't go into
business with a man that cheats on his
wife because if he has no loyalty to his
wife um and to to God as well because
again adultery is is a major thing then
he will definitely have no loyalty to
you as a man or to to jump into business
with him um and to me that's a big red
flag big cut off and write off if you're
cheating on your wife not even going to
get a second wife or whatever you you
guys mentioned but if you're cheating on
your wife committing adultery zenner um
again I've said this before you're
putting firstly the woman's life at risk
because if you bring her disease now um
HIV all of the rest of it then it's a
big problem it's a big problem and to me
you're trying to kill me at this point
you've cheated and you want me to die
that's actually very valid I was hearing
a case of actually rude I was hearing a
case of like talking about sometimes um
these secret marriages and stuff like
that that happen sometimes with brothers
who want to get married again and they
have these secret marriages and then
what happens is this brother if you
think is's actually putting the life of
your first wife in danger yeah it's
actually reality and my teacher he was
telling me he was like he's really
against this uh there was one sister she
was like uh she wants to get married I
don't know if she's a I can't remember
but she was like you know no his that it
is like that Etc oh no no no he this
brother came and he was like can you do
the I've got this sister and he was like
yeah but have have you checked like like
you know if there's any like and he's
like no no but if my wife finds out he's
like I don't care he's like I'm putting
her life in danger if I if I allowed
he's like I refuse to do the n because
you need to make it clear to but he's
like yeah but see this is where men get
stuck a bit they're like yeah but if I
tell her it's all chaos if I don't tell
her her life isn't if I tell her my life
isn't danger if I don't tell her her
life is in danger so the the issue is at
hand true but I I think in a nutsh so um
why do men cheat man I don't know I come
from a Jah background like friends Etc
I've I've known I've known like men who
are in serious let's let's call them to
them marriage is like girlfriend like
they've been with this girl for L time
and they're just dyable they go clubbing
partying Etc you just you see the guy
bro you I don't think I had a friend in
jilah that was loyal to like it's to one
way or another and I think it boils back
down to our society that we live in
because as men we are visual creatures
that's our weakness that's what Allah
subh tells in the Quran to lower our
gaze yeah is very important because we
consume with our eyes and because the
greatest weakness for us is the opposite
gender for men like I I hear like
certain brothers would they're married
God-fearing and they be like bro I
didn't lower my gaze or saw this sister
in this shop or wherever and he goes W
it's as if something possessed my body
he goes I had to go and speak to her
even if it's for second marriage
whatever it is but and again I'm not
saying he has a justification that
matter but there's a strong pull and
this studies show this look why is there
excuse me just because we're adults here
strip clubs yeah why is there uh
prostitution why is there men's
magazines you don't see that you don't
see a woman going and saying I want to
see the cards of this guy it doesn't
exist as men we are visual creatures and
the society we live in makes it so much
more harder on us and we have the innate
desire which we are polygamous by Nature
so what happens is like you said there
are boys like idiots who um they they
and and I would say when you said oh I
wouldn't do business with them I would
say Nah if if I knew a guy who was
disloyal to his wife he was a Muslim I
would say bro the fact I'm the business
with you is cuz you violated Allah's
laws you don't care about Allah's law
you're going to care about mine move but
if I was a disbeliever and he was a I
would not see that as a disloyalty to
myself at all cuz men work in a
different way but again for him to
violate Allah's laws and you see we hear
stories of sometimes practicing Brothers
I hear that are being caught with
escorts bro literally and I'm thinking
to myself like bro why didn't you just
go get married again I don't I don't
understand the psychology I would love
to know what's going through the mind of
these brothers it's because a lot of men
they don't want the commitment of a
second Financial burdens they want to
have their shortterm pleasure they don't
want that commitment that's that's what
most guys that's why they cheat so I
don't agree with men want to cheat
because they're polygamous by Nature
they just want to cheat because it's fun
exciting or you know what I mean they're
hiding it escorts are a onetime thing
gone you're not going to see them again
it's easy to do you know what I mean so
so it sort of brings up a question then
you mentioning how like you wouldn't
want to do business with someone who's
like cheated or done Z right what if
he's repented what does sort of Allah
what does Allah say about someone who's
I'm talking about somebody who's
actively doing that not somebody who's
not who's someone who's repented and if
they have repented though would you
still consider their potential I would
firstly it's hard to tell isn't it like
if somebody's actively cheating and
doing all these bad things but obviously
if somebody's repented and has changed
their ways then of course it's but again
it's still a character flaw I'll still
be like sideways like cuz what if a
better opportunity comes up he's always
going to have that inkling to basically
snake you off and then go and get that
better opportunity at the detriment of
you so for me I'm like yeah I would
prefer not to deal with that but and I I
understand that men are humans like
we're all humans we're all going to have
desires we're all going to have an
inkling and I I understand it some men
genuinely I don't excuse it I don't
condone it but some men
genuinely have tried with their women
like they will try they'll try they'll
try and the woman is not giving him his
rights and then out of a fluke or a one
night stupid mistake he will go and make
that huge mistake yeah but I also feel
like there are a lot of men and maybe
you guys can answer this for me who have
this um like opposite life where they
their wife at home they don't want her
to wear makeup they don't want her to
fix up they want her to look like plain
J the woman that they're cheating with
is all doled up looks good and like
they're like that's and how is that
meant to make your wife feel when you
know she's found out that you've cheated
with bloody Sierra or somebody who looks
absolutely amazing and then you put her
in this cage and you don't want her to
wear makeup you don't want her to look
good she barely does her hair she's just
always at home like it's that can also
Force the woman to now go the opposite
direction that's really difficult for
women to handle sometimes but I don't
call them real men there to be honest if
there's a real man I think first of you
need to have self-control self-control
on yourself and and the thing is trying
to keep yourself away from Z know but if
you got attraction at home if you got
that attraction with your wife and you
got everything there you will never ever
think of cheating but this is what I'm
talking about real men but there are
some men that there they just cheat
because they can even some women know
about it their wife know about it but
they don't do nothing about I think a
lot of people don't understand the rules
that we have like beautiful rules that
we have like if you like to eat too much
fast if you like money too much give
from what you love give s give Zak if
you um and again if you do have those
strong desires fast pray fast
like calm yourself down it's not every
day like oh my I'm going to go out there
cheating sometimes relax I think
sometimes it probably be based on ego as
well do you know how you're saying
you're questioning why does not a guy
marry the other one maybe he's got this
ego behind that if he's got going to
leave and get remarried obviously his
wife is then going to get married to
someone else and maybe that's something
course of course like like this is this
is this is where it's a fin line you
know at the end of the day as as men we
have the power of
um because we don't we don't like no man
wants his wife to be unless he's
repulsed by her like he's he's had
enough of her that's why the third talak
if romaner talak he's calculating his
head him her being with another woman I
don't care move I just do know what
nothing to do with that that's why that
that protocol is in place but as men
generally just disagreeing with sister
Amir and brother Sage please don't kill
me after
yeah we yes it's true like when it comes
to cheating a man like before a Muslim
man who cheats to me it's a very low
category man like he's a very very low
category man in the sight of Allah and
in front of my eyes because for you to
violate look you can violate a woman's
rights that's wrong you've gone against
the H you can but to violate Allah's law
you're tapped in the head to me you're
AB normal bro you're in a different
planet to violate Allah's law to me
makes you I will not trust you in
anything like you said like anything at
all but the thing is yeah we as men we
desire multiple women and I have to to
say this outspokenly why because this is
the reality the inbuilt the way as men
are hardwired so because I believe this
is the reality because in Jia I would
see these brothers these not these
brothers these men that I used to be
with who would have girlfriends they
were in the wrong relationship with and
they would like want to get married to
them or Etc but bro they will go on
holiday bro I'm telling you br the
moment they land it can't be all of them
bro all of my friends I do not and you
might say okay you had some really bad
friends man I've had friends in
different places in many years Etc
there's some consistency that you see
bro even my culture I come from a
Kurdish Turkish culture yeah bro a lot
of men are dyed their wives I can look I
don't need to go into detail yeah I know
distance uncles this that bro I'm
telling you they would even go to
escorts prostitution it's just and I'm
looking that's why when I was looking
into Islam and I found out about this
whole polygamy thing I said that makes
damn perfect sense but to who not to
this man who was promiscuous but a man
who gives the right to his wife and I
say any man for that matter who wants to
go get married which another story his
reference and I this might be extreme
for anyone I believe his reference
should be his first wife that's how good
your relationship with your wife should
be that when you're getting married if
your second wife asks who's your
reference you say my wife is my
reference I believe that kind of men
deserve that but since we're talking
about cheating men are just visually
attracted and that just and like you
said you're talking about fasting I let
me tell you something I don't know what
kind of fasting you can do you'll have
to be maybe on the verge of of starving
to death that you're like I care about
more about chicken than something else
yeah yeah it has to be because he needs
to be it genuinely doesn't work yes the
prophet peace be upon him said if you're
not married why fast because maybe you
haven't um had that's why the punishment
is 100 lashes for a single person
because you haven't had intimacy because
if you did do you know what's
interesting about the Sharia the Shar
makes sure the society on a micro level
to micro level is fixed meaning we as
men when we go outside we don't see a
flipping chocolate bar with a half naked
woman we thinking what the has the bar
what to do with this woman
we're not exposed to that our sisters
are dressed that properly we don't have
trigger points you get it and then if a
man that's what Allah says in the Quran
what Allah has allowed you and what your
right hand possesses the concubines and
after that anyone that transgresses
you're you're an transgressor why
because Allah seeing there is nothing
for you to be triggered off there is
nothing out there for you to do now
you're going to go and commit adultery
of course you're going to get capital
punishment because there's nothing
triggering did you get it but this is
why I feel like living here in the UK in
detal leaves men and women in a constant
state of cognitive dissonance because we
are trying to be within the dean we're
trying to be you know strict and on the
straight line but yet our surroundings
as much as we try to have community over
sexualize it's so hard you just step out
your house and you're you're
tempted us as men you need to understand
the way we are tempted we work on look
tell you something well I would love I
would love if there was just this device
where you guys be in our shoe for 20
seconds brother and look we are men we
know yeah look we could Brothers can be
chilling here a sister can just walk in
and say I forgot my bag and walk out our
whole body and demeanor will change
right you look at a brother he's looking
a bit his shoulders are gone a bit he's
like what happened to this brother
brother the impact that you have on us
you guys cannot imagine that's why
that's why let me tell you that's why
with men well you guys don't understand
the severity
I was speaking to one sister she's from
Saudi okay she was laughing she goes
sorry to go around sorry but she was
saying basically go what I was like
there's men who get you know aroused by
a woman's angle she start laughing and
there was Brothers there was brothers
and there was brothers and I the
brothers and the brothers were like is
she for real she was deluded really she
was laughing I was like you have no idea
what planet we live you know one thing
though you know how you say in the west
right like you know we're quite
unfortunate in the sense where we see
like you know women naked everywhere men
naked everywhere whatever but even in
Arab you hear all these stories
about you know they do it in secret they
have these parties and stuff crazy
parties alcohol the whole Lots there
right so the West we can't just keep
saying the West is bad you know we can
blame on the west Etc Arab countries are
just as worse if not worse cuz they're
hiding can
I but do you know why everywhere the
exactly everywhere let me tell you why
when you constrict something to such a
level I don't believe I believe for
example in interaction with the opposite
gender if it's necessary that's the
reason why for example when certain
people accuse of free mixing there
should be a civilized interaction when
you turn like sisters are here oh let me
jump through the
wall she is a human one she's a human
being have
some yeah if you talk to her with an and
a mother she she's our honorable sister
a talk bro there are people who would
rather go and speak to a cfir woman or a
cfir man than a Muslim I find it weird
it's a different topic in itself but
this is what happens when you go to
extremes bro this is the reason I've
heard stuff in Saudi Arabia crazy bro
they are more of an a mad one but I
believe it goes but anyway we don't want
to digress sister okay so um what I want
to say is men and women both cheat we
know that now why is this the main
reason from my own belief system I
believe is because the soul is not
connected to allaha the soul cannot
connect to another the human being on
that level what we're looking for you
know soulmates and all this I don't
believe in that I think the only
connection you can have of the soul that
we're looking for that fulfillment that
that feeling of you know that feeling
we're looking for you can't have that
with a human being you can only have
that with Allah subhana wa ta'ala
so when we have that connection when
we're on our Dean that forces us to then
lower our gaze that forces us to not
watch that program that we're going to
watch on Netflix you you will be
repulsed by that you'll be repulsed by
all these things I think for men is a
very important thing is self-control and
how does that come comes through that
connection with Allah and our our Dean
teaches us discipline our Dean is dis
thing is like I work in um I work in the
places that loads of women there but I
have alhamdulillah I have self-control
so the thing is that self-control is
very very important for a man is hard to
do it is but we have to self-control and
the thing is even when you do something
like I'm just saying if I did do
something I'll feel guilty because I'm
not even just cheating on my wife I'm
cheating on my kids as well what else
would make you feel guilty what what
other element of guilt is there in that
if if you lot but the thing is like the
thing is of course Allah Allah is
watching me all the time but it's that
guilt as well that you have to think
about as well so trying to find things
that will stop you from committing that
Z looking away or like making the
conversation can I ask you a question at
what age did you get to that level where
that belief system kicked in or were you
always like that um uh my thing is when
when I was I think some men have it in
their character where they're just
actually women and men some women are
really once they're married that's it
they obessed with their husband some men
are the same like they're cool they're
not you know hot in their temp so
they're just calm and they have that
character it's how they were brought up
as well I think the fundamental reason
why men cheat is because of porn like
genuinely that is the
most most people who cheat like they'll
tell you um I asked them like is it have
you watch porn do you watch porn
regularly be like yeah I do but they
can't see a correlation there it's how
you VI so the human element is no longer
there they don't see but the fun thing
is even if someone's praying they're on
Dean all it takes is to look up porn
once and it's the sole connection with
Allah the thing is I've seen it with a
lot of men because they cheat because
they can they can cheat they get away
with it some some women know that the
men cheat but they just let them go but
this is another thing that when your man
you know your man is cheating you need
to put like that's it because if he
knows you can get away with it keep on
doing but before we get to that stage is
the communication between the husband
and the wife is so important that when
there is an issue or there's a problem
yeah we have to be able to say and talk
to our partner for example if I'm
working and I've got a mini bus and
sometimes I don't know who my passengers
are and there could be loads of women it
could a hot sunny day and I'm in the
park we can go out anywhere I would you
would always remind and confidently talk
to my wife and say listen I'm always
coming back towards you because you're
my wife and you know this is how the
reality is I know sometimes you can be
tired whatever but you need to be able
to talk to your wife because sometimes
she's busy she's got kids she's had a
whole busy day doing X Y and Z she then
needs to do you know whatever she needs
to cook and by the time you come home
you've got 1 hour to chill eat food
she's knocked out in bed and you're just
sitting
there you need to be able to talk and if
you establish that connection with your
wife by talking about the things that
sometimes people would find shy as to
talk dep depends how you talk to your
wife because if you say that to your
wife your wife will say why do you feel
like that no I'll just say you can only
pick up I think sometimes like I said
it's about mat I'll just say you can
only pick up the
elderly no I'm just talking about I'm
talking about it could be anything I'm
talking about going to the park but
whatever it is that you people do you
understand some people have professions
like taxi drivers and they're oneon-one
in a in a taxi car for you're sitting in
work in a in a call center and there's
lots of people I know incidents like my
wife when she was when I got married to
her I said there ain't no working for
you but when she was working she was
telling me incident in her workplace in
Tower hamlets Council where Muslims are
cheating on their partners with the guy
that they're working with you understand
so why put yourself in that environment
and that's where it balls up you say tuo
at the same time but at the same time
why put people in that situation where
cheating can take place ask question you
understand so you have to have a balance
as
cheating what would you guys class as so
same thing we discussed when we said why
women cheat it's there's two there's two
ways of doing it sort of physical
cheating everyone can say that's
cheating right physically doing
something but also emotional and when I
say emotional I mean like it could be
flirting could be engaging entertaining
other women you only engageing women if
it's a necessity right anything outside
of that if you're flirting with them you
know discussing this and that I feel L
cheating I wouldn't be with I wouldn't
be with
the a girl picture is that cheating yeah
yeah why would you need like another
girl picture does sense do that's a form
of disloyalty men don't cheat
emotionally womenat
emotionally as a man emal need no man
says I'm emotion no no men don't cheat
it's very simple it's very we're very
straight to the point yeah because of
desires a man is bored of his wife um he
doesn't like pornography not lowering
the gays fundamental key aspects here
that's what they cheat and cheating is
for example that a a Muslim man who's
God-fearing uh that he can have an
option of getting married again chooses
to go and sleep like commit Zen that's
that's cheating yeah had a problem from
he could have had a problem from he need
to fix that problem I know I know that
I'm saying some sometimes people have to
rec that and that sometimes and it's
unfair for the the woman that sometimes
you we don't know who we've got married
to because people want to hide the Bad
and the flaws exactly they might have
been addicted to porn they might have
been having loads of girls and now they
want to change yeah you know now they
want to change and they they're probably
still on that stage of working it out
they I tell any revert brother
specifically brothers when they come to
Islam you need to detox for get married
for a good couple of years because
you're coming from mad jilia if you live
that club and partying bro you are us it
in your system to be speaking
to lowering the Gaze is not even a this
this concept of lowering the gay before
I came to Islam I was like what do you
mean l Gaz you don't know nothing about
but some people actually got married in
that situ bring very important question
here yeah there's a slight contradiction
CU in the previous episode we were
talking about men have emotions now I
want you to explain okay A man is not
emotionally connected to that a man is
not emotionally connected to that woman
which I believe
yeah a man can have a relationship but
there's no emotional connection he's
connected emotionally to his wife but
then at the same time you're saying that
men are emotional so can you answer that
question when we talk about how do how
do emat when you say emotional obviously
I I know on a deeper level there there's
many reasons for it but um can you
explain to our viewers that what is the
difference between not having that
can you your question so sorry if you
cheat that's an emotional response
that's emotional period no that's that's
that's to you emotional he's talking
about emotionally so for example I'm
flirting with a girl on
Instagram can I I know men I know men in
J who would go and be with multiple wom
and it means it's like you know what is
it's like drinking water you just drink
it and it means nothing to
you I'm not saying a connection but it's
still an emot
because to say that you you you're now
going to cheat even if you have no
connection to the woman what you've done
is an emotional response no problem if
it's an emotional response what what I'm
seeing is a man let me make this very
clear please tell me if I'm wrong a man
could go and be intimate with another
woman and it can mean zero to him it's
like it's like he went there it's like
he went he said yeah I just kicked the
ball and I came back it means nothing to
him not for a woman when a woman does
that she's gone past beyond that stage
of her husband is dead in her eyes
because the respect has been lost cuz in
a in a modest in ha she doesn't even
think of that the moment she thinks of
that and does that that's why in the
workplace you guys were mentioning that
woman has lost respect for her husband
long time ago she he left she left her
time ago she she just acting up on that
now so the way that's why in the last
episode we said women emotionally when
they neglected they cheat but then it
can become physical but it doesn't need
to become physical they can say you know
what I get my emotional satisfaction
from this guy at work and at home I G my
intimacy from my husband that's why a
man should be in tune with that but your
question was if I'm not mistaken my
question is can you explain to the
viewers when we say emotion now you're
telling the viewers that a man is not
emotionally connected to that woman that
he cheats with yeah so how is that
different to a man having emotions so
now you're saying a man does have
emotions but then when he's connected
with that woman how can he just set his
emotions aside okay so as men what we
say is that for example when we
discussed about if our wives has given
birth and she says some really hard
stuff to us we say we're mentally weaker
that can bother us that can hurt us
we're human beings however we are also
transform us we transform you know like
the the machine the car turns into a
thing yeah we we do not use that or
carry that on to like for example if a
brother is being like his wife is giving
bit of a slack we all get that yeah if
any man thinks that he's going to go to
another woman it's going to be resolved
you're an absolute idiot and you're a
child we say that when that happens that
bothers us but when we are argument if a
man wants to go and have a second wife
and or he wants to go and cheat and at
that point he an emotional connection
there's a disconnection in the sense
because he's thinking I want intimate
for example um sorry to get into detail
my wife is I'm not talking about my wife
I'm saying this man imagine him saying
I'm happy with my wife but there's this
other woman her eyes or her leg or
whatever other body part I just desire
that thing that she look it's an
inanimate object there was a study done
that men were shown women that were
dressed half naked the part of the brain
lit up for Tool use you know a
screwdriver or a she he saw her as an
inanimate object yeah that is the brain
of our brain animal Instinct animal
Instinct of I get what I want and I'm
gone there's no that's the reason why
Allah tells a woman to cover up the
reason why Allah tells a woman to cover
up is so we don't fall in love the wrong
way not love fall in love lust is the
wrong way because it protects you and it
protects me cuz when you're covered I'm
speaking to you not speaking to
something else yeah so a man's man drive
his primitive brain we this is the
reason why I believe men cheat because
to us the way we are programmed and
wired is we want it its reproduction and
also having variety so because of that
to us is very that's why I say polygamy
has sent to protect the woman because a
man has this animal Instinct where Allah
says hold your horses if you are going
to do it here's the askcar hand marriage
and he's thinking Rob I'm primitive I'm
just like animal he's saying you are an
animal then you stay as an animal if you
want to do it like a human being here's
the protocol so that's why I believe
polygamy protects the woman but because
we don't have the element and there's a
whole who about it that's a different
story men go down the root of doing it
in an animal Instinct so how they how
can they control that okay good so what
I'm saying is number one connection with
Allah subhana wa tala vital and
fundamental I know many brothers who
came from a
Jah in in that aspect and I'm just
speaking sorry cuz I have some
experience in that sense where I would
tell them brother please don't think
about marri for the 2 years you have to
go through rehab detox because you don't
know what La The Gaze is you chat to
Left Right Center woman everywhere you
you have been with multiple women bro
you how you going to come yes in Islam
he allows you four wives but w i Am pro
polygamous polygamy but I will never
ever tell a brother who's come to Islam
your solutions for wives I say you got
the disease in the heart fix the disease
in the heart you need to detox startop
watching pornography stop talking to
woman once you've done that build a
level of tawa you pray your Salah you
fast you give your charity then once you
do that I know some brothers who say you
know what bro I'm okay with one wife
because you've cleansed your inner
disease no woman you could have hundreds
of wom W there won't be enough so it's
an inner thing you need to fix stop
watching pornography lower your gaze
because there are always more beautiful
women than your wife stop looking the
eyes the heart doesn't desire what the
eyes don't see so there's an internal
disease that needs to be fixed
connection with Allah subhana wa tala
and believe me after that a brother
thinking second wife that's long that's
you I'm trying to say but if he still
has that like the brother like whoever
for that matter I'll be honest we all
even my brother tried to hear but he got
I'm joking no you so in a nutshell what
I will say then if you say you know what
I do want to okay because at least your
Affairs internally are fixed you're not
going to oppress her because if you get
a second wife it's not going to be
enough cuz you got watch your
pornography brother third four 500 wives
are not going to be enough so I believe
that's why I meant fix forgive me I
spoke too much I'll leave it to you I
also think what the sister said in the
middle about um having your Social
Circle um sort of having a good Social
Circle is such a big impact on how
you're brought up and how you act and
sort of hold yourself if you've got
friends around you that are going
clubbing cheating on their wives or
girlfriends or whatever right you're
100% going to be just as bad as them if
not worse and it comes down to what the
sister said and the WR well about
culture they kind of go hand in hand if
you come from a culture I don't want to
mention which culture but some culture
sort of encourage cheating oh it's
normal for these guys to do it get out
of your system even if you're married
just just do it get out your system then
come back the thing is in our culture in
our culture not even that I mean like
specific in our culture you got this
thing and they have they have arranged
marriage and uh if the guy is like they
say to her marry this girl and she's
part of the family marry her but do
whatever you want to do outside the
parents tell her that and the girl knows
about this and this is how it continues
when the kids grow up they think the
same as well so that's the first thing
but like what I see myself when I work
on the doors and stuff
what lot men like Brother Ali says like
a a woman is just a number for them
they're just just a number for them like
they're not connecting with no woman and
they go I can't find a woman it's like a
the things you do how are you going to
find a woman the things you do because
you're not going to find a woman just
taking them as numbers so a a wife holds
high value for a month of course he does
so that's the only woman that can hurt
him emotionally the rest of the women
are just mean nothing mean exctly I'm so
sorry I'm keep but in but it's I I would
know Brothers they I keep saying
Brothers me J friends they would go to a
club they'll meet their wife to be
dressed up in a Min SK looking mash up
the wife her and say you never going to
the club Again by the way ever in your
life yeah and then they'll go to the
same clubs and do whatever they want cuz
you know you know you know why they
register in their head this is my go
this is my girlfriend or wife whatever
done now I'm going to I value her and
she's mine but the rest are nothing and
today women they have no so they throw
theirself at these days women are
throwing theirself at men and now men's
weakness so he makes the situation more
worse so for a man in his mind he's like
this is my girl this is my wife but the
other woman they just nothing it's just
literally W piece of paper that's how it
means literally I can give you an
example of what he just said there so
I've he used to be a friend but he met
someone at shishan right and um you know
they got together discussing marriage
whatever she cheats on him all the time
like yeah I hear about it and I'm
thinking yeah Muslim I'm thinking bro
what do you expect you met her at Shisha
Lounge like the most B she of Birmingham
ever you expect to wife her up just like
that she's got a background of doing
this and that do you know what I mean so
why would you assume that she's going to
be yours and just yours doesn't make
sense I'm confused sorry so because she
went to a Shisha Lounge that makes no no
no so that's why I said the most bait
Shea L and plus
shaa is aren't places you're supposed to
meet signant other
anyway if I go to sh I ain't going to go
chat to every girl and think yeah this
one's the wife people can change I
totally agree you can be look look you
can people can change but sometimes the
atmosphere and the area there is we need
to generally specifically people can
change 100% up hand but generally if
you're being in a specific area where
mad stuff are happening and a woman's
coming from there I do not see that as a
woman to marry if this same for not
just alic we're not supposed to be doing
and stuff like that like I feel like in
the UK anyway it's become like a it's
become like a Chill Zone and the
most
social I'll give you some we talk that
is
sometimes groups of girls go to sh and
they're just group of girls in shisha
lounges it doesn't mean that they're
hores going to
cheat the area in itself is a question
so I'll give some context to that like I
said
is bait in the sense it's like a club in
there there's music going people dancing
everything like that I should have
prefaced that before I said every sh
shange that specific sh is known to be a
bit like you go there to get what you
want sort of thing in it so I should
have said that to start with yeah I you
been Qui just struck my head I was just
thinking about it for the last 10
minutes so I was going to start with
just this tqu itself you know Allah last
say is obvious if it's for Quran it's um
Allah won't change the condition of the
people until they change what themselves
so you have to start with your
relationship with Allah and you have to
build a Taqua and once that's
established even if there's wrong things
in front of you you will be more
equipped knowing Allah is by your side
that you will be able to resist it age
totally and then I don't know if it's
Quran orith because I was just reading
it a couple of days ago it's love for
your brother what you love for
yourself so then if you're in that state
of you have the TAA and the fear of
obviously I'm not going to be that
person that's going to go out and cheat
if there's someone that you know that's
in the process of doing that you would
be the first person to say you should
not be doing this and then you give the
why and obviously what a lot of men they
don't like is being told that they're
wrong and obviously another
thing guys men men have too much pride
to admit that they're wrong 100% men
like to fix up man if you make mistakes
yeah yeah yeah we want to fix up all the
time that's a bad let me tell you why
women hate accountability so do men no
okay before before you say
anything sometimes you see these videos
yeah they come up and a woman's CAU
cheating what's the first one she says
it's cuz of you it's cuz of you it's cuz
a man would be like you know what listen
yeah but men and women do human respon
that's your experience that's your
experience it's a human response people
like to deflect put the blame no one
likes to take accountability I don't
think it's a man or woman
thing I just want to say something first
of all I think before anyone cheats man
or woman think you have to understand
how would I feel
if my other half did that where would
that put me so it's about about before
you take that step think if someone does
that to me how is that going to impact
me as an the problem with that is a lot
of men think it's okay to be cheating
but when the sister no then they they
should have that they should have that
similar mentality is different I I
understand the mentality is different
but there's such a thing as empathy as
well empathizing but at the same it is
it is I was just going to quickly say
sometimes these are topics that we
should be probably having before
marriage at the time and then if you're
in a situation where we want to start
talking about tuer in our relationship
then everybody that is listening to this
show or in marriage situations need to
be changing the whole entire life not
just about the TAA of breaking up or
cheating but everything else that leads
towards it like we were talking about
free mixing or your place of work
because everything then has to change
and the household has to change the
Dynamics has to change and it can't just
be the man it has to be the woman at the
same time working together you know you
know why all of us are prone to cheating
all of us it's the environment Aki what
protects us Aki if I'm in an environment
where there's half naked girls all the
time I'm a human being bro like I don't
even want to be there do you get what
I'm trying to say so every one of us you
have to lowering your gaze not watching
this stuff abstaining from this stuff
going into areas where you have good
friends are fundamental otherwise
actually it's not a religious issue
people think it's like a religious issue
you can bring the most righteous person
who's a yeah if you put him in a certain
area he can fall into F it's it's it's
the area it's not just internal is
external as well but I believe Brothers
also have to follow modesty especially
nowaday you know Brothers flexing and
all that and I think sometimes TV I
think TV plays a massive I think that's
kind of based down to society yet again
and as far as you're saying that oh you
should feel how the spouse feels if you
a cheat I think a lot of people the
reason why they cheat is they think this
spouse deserved it and they should
understand that you know you're you're
talking you're talking from a
perspective of of a woman a man's whole
dynamic is different I'm going to let
you speak then sister an then you and
I'm going to wrap up in yeah if anyone
else want have a question yeah sure so
let's do yourself sister Kon then sister
an and then sister and then we're going
go
to yeah so I think there's something
called self-respect as well you should
have that self resect in yourself that
you're capable of having self discipline
and control and I think that's where it
kind of Lies just having that belief in
yourself that you can respect your
values as a Muslim being
so so when we're talking about um our
Social Circle um I just want to touch up
on that we I think one of the most
reasons is also because sometimes when
you're around you know your friends and
they're in that environment where you
know they're going clubbing partying
whatnot anything you feel that you know
is a bad influence on you sometimes
brothers or sisters don't remove
themselves from that situation and I
feel like staying in that environment
eventually leads you to you know go out
and cheat I feel once once you feel like
there's a surrounding which you're in is
a bad influence and you just remove
yourself from it and that is also what
your sister just said self-respect as
well you don't have to certainly feel
Under Pressure to go and you know commit
you know do cheat on your spouse just to
fit in your Social Circle it doesn't
work like that and I understand that
there's a lot of people who don't have
the ability to understand influences
around them but once you feel you're in
a circle that's you know leading you
down the wrong path then just remove
yourself from that situation right there
and then because it's eventually going
to you know um influence you and impact
you in a bad way and that's with
everything as well actually I think in
general but um I was going to say so if
a man cheats uh would you guys say that
the woman should forgive him and stay it
all depends on that's up to her yeah it
all depends on if the man I think it
depends on that if he if he cheated and
the thing is I think there should be
certain type of thing because you want
him to know that how serious you are
because if you let him go really like
quick just like that he's going to do it
again because he thinks he can get away
with it is a human
nature circumstances as well that you
have to take in consideration for
example marriage children you know your
network you can't just completely say
yeah you forgive but you can't
completely say yeah you're going to end
what let me ask an interesting question
that will put some Dynamics in place um
let's say for example yourself if your
partner I don't want to say cheat let's
say another woman's involved second wife
or second wife orat no cheat cheat cheat
yeah cheat cheat because for me cheats
on me I'm not forgiving it okay what if
his second wife but that's the thing
because for me if you cheat I'm not
forgiving it CU you had the opport
opportunity or the the the um you know
you have light to actually go and get
married to a second wife in the right
way so if you go behind my back and you
cheat on me I'm you're done the fact
actually have say m sister may Allah
bless you the fact that you distinguish
between the two and one is more severe
it's very good thought process to have
so yes if if argument sake the husband
was to cheat as a as a wife how would
you be more you be forgiven obviously
forgiven doesn't mean okay yeah let's
just hold down but eventually think like
I says it's back to circumstances I
meant as women uh men is is about they
just need to obviously satisfy the
themselves but women we are more
connected from the heart okay and we
take a lot of things into consideration
this sorry it's a
reality wom do sacrif not true but would
you accept that women are very emotional
like that emotional would you
but you guys have been saying that like
throughout the thing about you know
women are more emotional and if a woman
cheats as an emotional cheater like I
don't believe that and I know a lot of
girls who genuinely do exactly what men
do they literally will go with men and
it's like nothing to them and there's
more and more women that are like this
today by the way let tell you and I
think we're generalizing where this
women are just emotional emotional I
don't think that I think that's a the
I'm I'm going to tell you why I'm going
to tell you why this happens I just want
a quick question so I can just I just
want to point something generally would
you forgive just just quickly yeah
generally I think based on my heart I
would find it very difficult but I think
based on the situations I would take as
a mature person I would take everything
into consideration but you're more keen
on forgiving um it depends at the end of
the day we are human being every human
being does make a mistake in life now
depends how that other person has uh
regretted their mistakes or how many
times it has happened so I think it
depends okay so so what about yourself
just just generally I don't want to go
into personal details but would you say
I believe generally women are forgiving
in this aspect they are I have to be
honest Am I Wrong would you say that
sister for forget I would not forgive it
at
all I'm not for it I'm more I know my
relationship will be toxic afterwards
because I'm going to bring it up every
single argument I'm going to bring it up
every single second if you had kids
providing Financial stability that's why
a lot of women are I I'll be honest with
you bro I genuinely kids won't hold me
down I tell you that I genuinely I I I
believe if the instances for example um
i' I've seen in Jia these guys get
caught Etc and they get forgiven from
what I know gen women forgive but not to
a certain extent if you say a no a lot
of women do forgive a for okay good cuz
simple question would you ever forgive
if your wife
would for would you if my wife yes no
would you would you Over My Dead Body
but then I would I would expect my
to by the way by the way expecting the
women to forgive them to
forec I'm talking about a psychological
issue here now by the way I'm going to
say inshallah cuz Allah subh contest and
can put you in your place if Allah Wills
as men to us it's like you hang me is
better for women generally no no it's
for women that's I'm trying to the
reason I'm saying is to show the
disparity to understand each other
better for us it's a violation on
another level you know why because when
it comes to
intimacy like I said again we're adults
the ACT is being done on the woman it's
a it's like it's like somebody like does
it look honorable if if I'm there like
there's a there's a man and I'm punching
his face with a hammer does it look like
to his family he's in honorable State no
so the act in itself for us men it's so
much more severe in our heads than uh
for you guys I believe that's why you
guys are more forgiven now just just to
wrap up on something you said a lot of
women do it now yeah do you know why a
lot of women cheat let me put this cheat
I'm saying cheat a lot of women will be
with a man and it feels like
nothing now stud show a woman a lot
woman you know why and tell me if I'm
wrong sisters yeah if you find a man who
is God-fearing who has tawa who prays
who's a good man who's a good father who
earns he's a go-getter he's doing his
thing Etc would you ever ever ever think
of another man ever the best you got no
no please can you be vocal about it
please I'll be I'll be honest even if he
didn't have those things I'm too I'm too
fearful and loving of Allah that I would
never ever doah that's good may Allah
bless and preserve all of you I know you
guys are all the same but no we're not
this this is the thing we're
humans people make mistakes stupid
things I want to come from a human I
want to come from a human perspective
cuz I want to prove something for you
guys yeah I'm coming from perspective
yeah a woman is monogamous by Nature if
she finds a man who is a high value man
in the Islamic sense God-fearing has TAA
praying and he's he has good living he's
a good strong man Etc a woman would
never ever ever think of another man
done M I want to ask you guys a question
now Brothers if you was a wealthy man
who's God-fearing who's a millionaire
who's got your resources a man would
have would want another woman in his
life the difference is this between us
if you found your ideal perfect man you
would still think you would never think
of
another let me tell you very clearly
find my ideal perfect man if you find
let me if you find your ideal perfect
woman she is dropped dead gorgeous
beautiful look we know examples of Jay-Z
Kim Kardashian Kash Beyonce these are
women a lot of men could seem as really
good-look they have been treated on the
point is this as men that's the point
what we're seeing is when a man does it
he's doing it because it's a desire
there's no emotional connections Etc so
one of the reasons why men go and I
wouldn't say cheat get another woman or
desire another woman is because there's
an inbuilt mechanism in place that
triggers it it has that's why I say to
Sisters it has nothing to do with you
there's no deficiency it's that Primal
Instinct that happens some sometimes so
the difference I believe it's that men
do it because of it's just an instinct
which is not right but we're talking
about getting another wife Etc okay
that's a different story that's that's a
different story but what we're seeing is
do you see the difference between us and
you if you got that guy you never think
of it and with us men it's not like that
but this
isolog how they have been brought up
that's it's biologic just just like it's
a biological way that Allah has created
woman to be next level jealous if a man
wants to get married again it's just how
you are in your F then it's the issue on
how do control that both people have to
control that that test that Allah has
let's up we've talked about Solutions
yeah okay so any last words because we
have talked about Solutions pornography
bad friends environment conditioning
your mind because a lot of men are
condition to I I've seen this happen
where they go for like you mentioned
actually Kim kashian the Beyonce they go
for women who to them look good
aesthetically but their character is
that's why marries fail
exactly cuz you're just going for the
visual the look and then her character's
rubbish you know and then a lot of these
relationships fail because you've just
gone for surface level even if doesn't
change does not change she you know what
he'd do he would he would be treating
her like a queen a princess but that
deep instinct is still there for him I'm
just letting you guys know it is deep
built in us we don't ask for it we we
don't please don't blame us let's ask
the same question to
brother
brother thing we do we do have it but we
have to control
itol when able to control it okay
you it's a desire for something that you
have control yes it is I'm so sorry it
I'm soorry on this show I've decided I
took an oath speak the truth even if
it's against myself Allah say in the
Quran speak the truth even if it's
against yourself control okay we can
talk about controlling but you are not
sinful for exercising it and men should
not be blame worthy for exercis in it it
is normal as long as you're giv your
rights of your wife Etc I'm talking
about cheating by the way I'm not
talking about that I'm saying please
Brothers stop suffocating yourself CU
you go and do dumb stuff by going to
escorts you violate Allah's laws okay
just because the emotions of a woman I
don't give a damn with all due respect
to any woman in her emotions if you are
a good man who practices God fears good
father and you are killing yourself
internally that you're going to bounce
and do some Madness committing Haram
rather go and get married again yeah
that woman is going to throw you in the
hell fight she's going to say you know
my husband please throw him in the hell
fight instead of me please do it in the
right way if you are I'm not asking
anyone to go and do it I'm saying if you
are please this is what we live with
this how we're created our sisters I'm
only doing this so you guys understand
us it's nothing personal we have no
problem with you it's the way we are
created I know it's hard for you guys
but I'm just making it clear can I just
say can I I have to I'm sorry I'm I'm
not saying this for but I believe when a
woman starts respecting her husband a
husband who provides emotionally
physically
financially she will respect that man so
much and trust him so much that she will
get to a point where she herself may say
to her husband it's okay you can bring a
second but a man has to reach that level
and not many men reach that level I
agree but the perfect example I want to
give is n Alam he was in that situation
wasn't he um Al yeah Alam when the lady
was trying to chase him and um
commit yeah yeah yeah so the thing is is
fear of Allah fear of Allah and
self-control he said prison is more
beloved to me has to Lear how example
for us know a lot of people demand
respect you cannot demand respect you
gain respect now if a husband gains the
respect of his wife to the highest level
self-actualization is the highest
highest level for a human being when you
reach that level whether you're man or
woman and you're on your Dean you have
that soulle connection with Allah
because when a if if a husband decides
to get married and the wife accepts it
she gets the uh value of mar yes exactly
and and so now if there is a sister
whose husband is you know he's gained
that respect from her most likely I
believe so okay true I agree with
trust what what if her husband says that
you have to gain my
love oh why you guys looking at me like
that if a husband if a husband says to
his wife um you know that sense it's
very simple for example if the husband
comes and says you're disrespecting me
and she said you need to earn my respect
okay he says you have to earn my respect
the husband says I feel like you're
disrespecting me as a man and she said
well you have to earn my respect imagine
the the the man the woman comes and says
I don't feel like you love me you're
affectional well you have to earn my
love oh you guys don't like it okay so
you guys okay so one second one second
why is it that a man has to earn his
respect but if the woman is saying look
emotionally you're not giving me love
yeah and then he says well you have to
earn my love okay so how does how do you
gain
respect indivual why are people
marrying their significant other without
respect or love okay good but what I'm
saying is this but one thing we need to
bear in mind a woman wants love a man
wants respect in if you go to each other
and say I want this no as a man we have
to take the responsibility and say no
matter what arguments I have I have to
show the affection and the love that has
to be there so for a for a man we want
respect there shouldn't be you have to
earn what does that mean if you married
to a vile H like an animal who is
outright violating you I'm not talking
about that but to use the words to your
husband like you need to earn my respect
is good as me saying you have to earn my
love okay gain is different earn is
different yeah earn is in like a
contract you give it's a give and take
gaining respect is when you respect
others and you respect yourself first
when you respect yourself you have those
boundaries in place why Mar men that we
do not respect exactly I don't I would
never marry my husband if I didn't
respect him do you see what I mean so
the respect Foundation wise before we're
marrying people that has to be the
somewhere along the lines you when you
marry someone you're respecting each
other okay
to respect you that's why they're Maring
you yeah but somewhere along that line
through arguments through whatever means
he's not he's not providing yeah he's
changed he's not looking after you he's
looking at other women where is that
respect going to go are you still going
to respect on a note we need we need to
end but on a note what you said for
example and I believe this if a man is a
true man who does this stuff W your wife
will stick by you even if I'm not
talking about cheating cuz cheating I
would say I would say that she has every
Islamic right to get for divorce
immediately that's the Islamic right but
if you do decide to get married and Etc
if you are a good man she will stick by
you I believe this is in the psychology
of a woman because if you treat her well
yeah you're a good man but you have to
be that good the woman has to also be on
on them the only way of course of course
100% 100% if you don't have that
connection with Allah subh tala there is
no way on earth a woman will accept
another I think in society it needs to
change as well we need to remind people
that committing zner is not good commit
cheating and stuff is not good you've
always got an alternative option if your
wife isn't agreeing to a second marriage
then you've got the option of divorcing
low category man yeah you're I think
you're a low category man if you can you
have an option Allah has given you and
you're violating that because you're
scared of your wife what a coward you
are man you're you're a little I don't
want to speak anyways I don't want
because you're a Despicable individual
that Allah's given you an option but
you're like oh no my wife are you
worshiping your wife is your wife your
lord weird I think it just goes back to
what he what you said about they just
they're too lazy to or they don't or
they're cowardly enough to to take
responsibility of a marriage that's
really what a boy like they're boys to
the boys who's watching this inallah
you'll be men uh to next time hope you
guys have got an idea why men go down
this route uh but yeah that's in we did
another episode of why women end up
being disloyal which was very insightful
by the way we we really really decipher
certain stuff and understood certain
things um again it's I believe Cross of
the m matters is men are leaders and
Allah's made it most of the times I
blame men if their wife is disloyal but
you can watch the episode why I say that
you might disagree till next time for
the B Trip
show the prophet sallallah alh wasallam
said whoever builds a Masid for the sake
of Allah subhana tala Allah will build
for him a similar house in jenah on that
day where Allah subhana tala tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atam weight of Good Deed you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra
[Music]
Rewards